this is our like what is it like uh
quarterly youtube
uh twitch uh rant
uh podcast yeah yeah i mean yeah i mean
i i i you know i know a lot of people
might not empathize with us because we
do talk about it you know a lot and i i
don't know if for an audience is tiring
ever but i kind of feel like we therapy
we need this every once in a while
otherwise we're just gonna like
otherwise we're just gonna have like
have this like emotion in us and we just
every time every so often i just need to
let out you know of course i just need i
just need to let out i feel like for
content creators uh it's healthy you
know and it's like to me
being able to talk to other content
creators about it it's a healthy way to
get
all of this like toxicity out of
yourself and just you know get on with
your life yeah you know i think uh
before trash takes definitely need to
talk to another content creator every
now and then just rent yeah just need it
because it's better to rent to another
content creator than do it on a video or
a stream oh yeah definitely
i got a question have you guys ever like
tried to explain when you're like going
through some controversy or something's
going on you have to try and explain it
to someone who just does not understand
youtube and it's just really involved oh
yeah it doesn't work
i'm just like don't worry about it it's
a little annoying right now
yeah yeah no like no hate against anyone
we explain it to because to to their
credit they tried their hardest to
understand what's going on but like i
don't get it
yeah i remember i had to like pretty
early on in my career when like you know
i was getting that like you know first
initial wave of like you know you're
you're you're notable enough in the
community now where people outside of
your community will find you yeah
corpse party was made something like
that
it
is just kidding but like you know when
you when you first start to get that
first wave and you're like oh [ __ ] i
don't know who to talk about i don't
know i'm getting canceled blah blah blah
even though it was like barely nothing
right i remember i was talking to one of
my schoolmates about it being like yeah
so like
these bunch of people like coming into
my you know comment section saying that
i suck and blah blah blah i remember one
of them was just straight up like just
tell them the [ __ ] off
i was like
yeah
thought about that
not an option unfortunately when you're
it's with one of me and uh many others
you know who i'm up against not not
really that easy is it yeah because it
really was that easy if if only because
like i remember like tr every time i've
tried to explain something that's been
going on in this in like the youtube's
field some controversy you're just like
oh okay so um this person said this and
it piss is pissing a bunch of people off
like holy [ __ ] twitter is getting angry
and then you talk to the person they're
like uh why why people getting angry and
you're just like
um i said this anime was bad
so this person said this anime was bad
and these group of people got pissed off
about it and then they go so why they
pissed why were they pissed off about it
and then you keep going layers and
layers deep until you get to a point
where you they just forget what the
original like reason people are getting
angry for now or it's to the point where
you like the more arguments come through
and the more lays down it goes you just
start to realize wait it's not a problem
there's no problem to begin with i'm
just making it yeah i mean like i
remember back in the day where drama
could be addressed with like one just
one short twit longer and now it's got
to a point where you need like a four
hour breakdown to like to like
understand like the full depth of some
of this drama and i like i don't know
when that shift happened when it was
just like okay now now you need a
[ __ ] thesis like it's a full-on
dissertation to like to like break down
the like a play-by-play of like the
entire months the entire month leading
up to this one tweet except instead of
one professor like marking it down it's
the entirety of the internet being like
but did you use correct citations for it
no marx do we have the receipts do you
have the receipts
yeah it's uh it's it's crazy it's crazy
how uh
how especially that side of this the
internet has evolved especially like i
think i think drama culture is kind of a
thing now where oh it's definitely well
i i see some content creators who you
know start off
start off doing their own thing and then
i don't know how or why but
a lot of a lot of people i've seen have
just slowly shifted into just like
drama channels you know maybe
intentionally maybe not intentionally
but it seems like every other upload
seems to be talking about some kind of
drama or some kind of consciousness
that's going on yeah it's very good for
business though oh definitely it's very
one of those things where if you're in
drama that isn't really drama like it's
something you you let's say yeah like
you said you have a bad take on anime or
something right those kind of
drama are just generally just
good for you because there's no real
downside because nobody nobody who
actually watches you gives a [ __ ] that
you said a show is bad i you know like
when i said 86 i didn't like 86 right
there's a lot of people mad about that
yeah but i doubt there was many people
who are like i can't watch trash taste
or connor ever again because he said my
favorite show is bad yeah
but maybe other people who are like
maybe some people who are watching you
or some people outside of it see this
drama and think this is really [ __ ]
stupid uh i might go check them out or
i'm more familiar with their name
through this drama because because drama
has a really good way of
i feel like a click on a drama video is
like much more engaging than a normal
class yeah so when you get like
a million views on a drama video yeah
the million views on that drama video
and maybe that's a generic gaming video
they're not equal like the drama
engagement and how much people are
invested is so much more yeah and
especially if it's something that paints
you in a good light or paints you in a
way that makes it look like you didn't
really do anything yeah then it's just
it's great for you because that now
you're just gonna get people who are
more invested in you people who think
that you've been done wrong and then
they're going to support you more yeah
so when these people do this [ __ ] and
they try and drag you in the drama this
is why a lot of
a lot of big twitch streamers get into
this kind of drama very often because it
is really good for solid solidifying
your base viewership they they want to
support you they will they will help you
and then people who see it and think oh
they weren't really in the wrong they
might come and check you out and feel a
bit more strongly about you because they
want to support you because they feel
like this is some [ __ ] that was done
to you i feel like a drama video is like
especially in like multiple successions
right now the same drama like every day
it's like it's almost like the world's
most engaging let's play yeah you know
in a sense where it's like you know
you're more likely if you're really into
like a drama video you're more likely to
come back to that part than a regular
gaming video i think i think it's just
the modern day reality tv show oh
definitely because like here's the thing
do you think do you think people
actually care about drama do you think
people like no only when it's like you
know clearly like there is a wrong
person who did a [ __ ] thing right but
like like 90 of youtube drama is not
yeah i think there is a there will be a
core audience that does feel betrayed
um but i think the majority people are
there just for the popcorn yeah i mean
because like i remember like the most
recent drama i can remember happening
off the top of my head right now uh is
the one that involved pokeman and ninja
right oh yeah and like obviously that
got like a lot of views um
and a lot of views when it came out and
a lot of people were discussing it but i
remember like my first initial reaction
to hearing about this drama that was
going on was
okay what the [ __ ] happened
how
as a content creator i was like trying
to like [ __ ] piece together who was
mad at who who did wrong to who how did
it lead to this situation and they were
like like it took philly d five minutes
to explain it and that's a lot for
phillyd
and like i'm just saying what one minute
russia is invading one minute for that
yeah five minutes of pokemon
it was like that i was like oh my god it
was like the majority of the video it
was crazy like i had i had like an
easier time understanding some of like
the world situation going on right now
and the world politics then than than
like how this drama started and the
evolution of this drama it was like so
surreal like trying to trying to figure
out why like what was going on right
because if me as a content creator who
knows the content creators within this
drama was like having trouble figuring
out because i wasn't there right at the
beginning yeah i can't imagine how a
general audience feels you know where
they're just feats where like it seems
like people are just seeing people talk
about this on their timeline and they
don't even like they don't even know
like that you get to a point where you
kind of are waiting for someone to tell
you who you should be angry at right or
who who's in the wrong and that's the
problem is that i feel 90 of drama is
not so much about like trying to uncover
the details and you know like gathering
the receipts and doing like a [ __ ]
criminal investigation into who started
it and who's the culprit who's the
victim it's literally just you see a
piece of drama like the pokemon in ninja
one right yeah and 90 of the audience
just goes okay so who am i rooting for
yeah give me give me two people to root
for give me two people to fight for all
right it's ninja and pokeman all right
uh well i like that person better just
from the one thing i've heard about them
so i'll just root for them yeah because
that's not always the case but yeah a
lot of it is like that though you have
to admit it a lot of it's like that
especially especially if you're not in
that community or don't give a [ __ ]
about that community yeah you know like
you know like if a bunch of like you
know uh [ __ ]
fashion youtubers right get into some
drama right like that's what they want
though yeah but that's what they write
all right but like i'm not going to care
about the details all i'm going to care
about is okay so who are the two people
in question and what is the general
consensus on these two people who are
fighting right like that's all it is to
me like other than that i don't give a
[ __ ] personally yeah yeah i i don't you
know even though it's good for business
i don't think a lot of these uh twitch
streamers try to get into this stuff
some of them some of them maybe do yeah
i know that i don't try to but i'm just
uh
brash uh
with my words and also not very good at
coming like explaining my arguments on
the spot as we all know from trash taste
yeah so end up getting into these things
a lot of people aren't good at
explaining their arguments on the spot
which i think is where the problem stems
from right because you know i i would
like to
think that we're all like very well
spoken and you know on the ball
when i want to be yeah you can be you
can be but like it's hard it's hard
where you have so many hours of content
around yourself just talking and just
not just trash taste but twitch
streamers as well and especially with
twitch streamers where they are
basically
on camera live in an audience like eight
hours a day plus you know there's going
to be a time where someone where you are
not as careful with your words where you
slip up a bit and that's just going to
happen you know it's uh
it's it's it it would happen to anyone
in the same situation you know
absolutely yeah yeah
that's deep
damn
nice deep that hit me right there
nice deep oh
god damn